the other guy who's in the news lately
for getting kicked out of the nfl seems
like they do that a lot yeah
as brian flores he was the coach of the
dolphins he's got a lawsuit against the
nfl now
he says it's a sham when they pretend to
interview black coaches for the job
there's only one black coach in the
league uh mike tomlin or the steelers
although next year there'll be three
but it's still a small amount out of 32
teams now
i i was a minority owner of the mets at
one point yeah
so i did sit on one owner's meeting
uh that's three hours i will never have
back
[Applause]
it was super boring yeah you know it was
about how much parking costs and you
know
it's my view was these guys just are
interested in money and making money and
also winning they want to be a hero in
their hometown
so
i'm not saying there isn't bias in their
minds but it's got to be unconscious
right because if they thought they could
make more money with the key hire which
is the coach
they
i mean it's hard to believe in 2022
even some old white owner would be like
you know i know this black coach is the
best but i just don't like looking at
him so much i'm going to
risk losing the season
is that what do you make of what's going
on my opinion is i kind of understand
you know that the relationship between a
owner and a coach is a very special
relationship
and my guess is a lot of the owners
don't really spend a lot of time around
black people that's probably right and
so they're just like it's just
uncomfortable like
i don't like how do i talk to them
and you know you're making this big
investment and you know this big company
right i understand you want to hire
someone that that you can relate to or
you feel you can relate
but does jerry jones really care
i mean he wants to win so bad because he
wants to be the big hero he wants to
ride in the parade on the big hat in
dallas
[Applause]
and is he really talking i mean it's the
coach and the players but they're 70
percent black that's what matters you'd
think that they would want to hire a
black coach if they thought that that
would produce a better result i think if
you could convince them of that they
they would they would but but even still
if we said okay we want to hire we want
to hire a african-american coach that we
think is going to give us a shot to win
what were they going to hire because
they don't get a lot of opportunities
they don't get a lot of opportunity to
show what they can do it's such a small
pool that they're choosing from right i
mean they almost always come from the
ranks of assistant coaches right and
it's their business they know all these
people
right
even before the owners don't the owners
don't the owners don't they don't okay
they don't
so what do you think about the part of
it where he says that he was paid to
tank games so that they could get a
better draft position well is it true
i mean i don't know i wasn't there but i
wouldn't doubt it because of what you
said right
money money and they want to win and if
you tank and you get a first pick right
you have a better chance you have a
better chance to win and i also think
that's part of it because
that's the way that they think okay and
when they're talking to
african-americans like
they don't know how african-americans
think and so
and you see what happened he mentioned
this to african-american coach
african-american coach ratted him out
right
you